mesdames messieurs bon dimanche depuis
vendredi le Conseil du Trésor et
l'Alliance de la fonction publique du
Canada sont en intense négociation pour
mettre un terme à la grève des 155 000
fonctionnaires fédéraux vendredi
Ottawa déposé est une nouvelle
proposition bonifiée au niveau salarial
mais aussi au chapitre du télétravail de
la sous-traitance et de l'ancienneté une
offre équitable concurrentielle
raisonnable mais surtout final indiqué
le Conseil du Trésor les deux parties
ont convenu de me faire aucune
déclaration publique durant ce blitz de
négociation combien de temps en temps
devrait-il négocier se rapproche-t-on
d'une loi spéciale le gouvernement
minoritaire de Justin Trudeau aura-t-il
la pluie d'un parti d'opposition je pose
la question au leader adjoint en chambre
du Parti conservateur Luc Bertone
monsieur Bertol de bon dimanche merci
d'être avec nous
déjà dit qu'ils allaient pas appuyer une
loi spéciale pour imposer le retour au
travail le bloc non plus il reste que
vous si on en arrive à ça allez vous
appuyer le gouvernement Trudeau
je pourrais malheureusement pas vous
répondre sur ça aujourd'hui parce que il
faut voir la loi deux faut voir ou en
sont les négociations et trois ben c'est
Monsieur Trudeau lui-même qui s'est mis
dans cette position là sont son ami de
sa coalition a choisi de lui tourner le
dos parce qu'il a trop tardé à revenir à
une entente avec les 155 000 employés de
l'État et Monsieur Trudeau doit tout
faire pour que tout ça se règle à la
table des négociations
vous savez ça fait déjà deux ans que ça
dure et malheureusement
le gouvernement comme c'est son habitude
d'attente toujours à la dernière minute
pour trouver et tenter de régler des
dossiers et on est face à une situation
qui est vraiment difficile aujourd'hui
causée par ce laxisme qu'est-ce que ça
vous dit qu'on en soit à la finale puis
que on a rien entendu depuis vendredi là
tout le monde est la taille est à la
table ça ne parle pas c'est de bonne
augure d'après vous
bah écoutez c'est sûr que quand on
annonce une offre finale les parties
particulièrement les syndicats doivent
prendre en considération beaucoup de
facteurs justement sont-ils prêts à
faire face à toutes sortes de mesures
que pourraient prendre le gouvernement
pour faire adopter
c'est cette négociation là donc on
comprend que ce silence peut être une un
bon signe qu'on s'en va vers un
règlement mais à quel prix pour les
Canadiens sont le sait pas encore
qu'est-ce que devront céder les employés
on le sait pas encore il y a beaucoup de
il y a beaucoup de questions plus de
questions à ce moment depuis des
questions mais là je reviens à ce que je
vous demandais originellement si ça sera
masse aux communes de va avec une loi
spéciale c'est parce que là on arrive à
une impasse c'est difficile c'est
difficile d'imaginer monsieur Trudeau il
faut il ne peut pas il ne pourra pas
compter vous n'êtes pas capable de dire
oui oui nous on est d'accord avec l'idée
de les ramener au travail ces gens-là
dans certainement pas on peut pas dire
d'avance appuyer les yeux fermés une
noix spéciale qui va justifier
l'incompétence du gouvernement à avoir
trouvé une solution avec ses employés il
faut voir qu'est-ce que serait cette loi
spéciale là si éventuellement il y en a
une mais il faut pas oublier que c'est
quand même spécial ce que le
gouvernement réussit à faire
d'augmenter de 21 milliards de dollars
les dépenses de la fonction publique
depuis 2015 et ne pas avoir été capable
de s'entendre avec ces syndicats vous
savez et puis je répète on dit souvent
depuis le début du conflit c'est le plus
important conflit des 40 dernières
années pour la fonction publique
fédérale et on nous parle souvent que
les conservateurs on est anti-union
entre syndicat puis tout ça mais du
temps je me suis un peu il y en a pas eu
de conflits avec la fonction publique
non plus vous avez utilisé spécial à
l'époque de Monsieur un peu quand même
pour amener au travail les postiers
entre autres
mais il y a pas eu de il y a pas eu de
grève de cet ampleur là avec la fonction
publique fédérale vous avez bon vous
avez beaucoup parlé de l'offre qui est
sur la table on faut voir là du fédéral
au niveau salarial
pour vous 9% sur 3 ans bah écoutez si on
regarde les conventions collectives qui
sont réglées dans le secteur privé au
cours des dernières années on parle de
deux.7 3 % donc je pense que là une
piste qui est intéressante pour les
syndicats est-ce que c'est suffisant
est-ce que ça dépend est-ce que les gens
veulent c'est une fonction publique qui
est efficace puis qui rend des services
c'est pas ce qu'on a vu au cours des
dernières années est-ce que c'est une
question de salaire est-ce que c'est une
question de motivation est-ce que c'est
une question de condition par rapport au
télétravail tout ça doit être sur la
table en ce moment et c'est pour ça que
c'est très difficile pour un parti
d'opposition qui a pas accès à toutes
ces informations là à toutes ces séances
de négociation là de vous dire est-ce
que 3% c'est suffisant dans un contexte
où on sait pas tout ce qu'il y a sur la
table en ce moment le télétravail l'idée
de conventionner d'inclure dans la
convention collective de télétravail si
vous formez le gouvernement vous allez
avoir géré cette question là aussi c'est
une bonne idée d'en faire une règle
couler dans la convention collective
je pense qu'il faut surtout certainement
entouré le télétravail faire en sorte
qu'on sache comment ça fonctionne que ce
soit équitable pour l'ensemble des
employés ce qu'on croit comprendre
actuellement c'est qu'il y a des
différences entre les différents unités
qui travaillent à gauche ou à droite
dans la fonction publique c'est pas les
mêmes règles tout dépendant des
gestionnaires donc c'est une bonne idée
de l'entourer mais encore une fois
qu'importe comment on entoure le
télétravail qu'importe si on l'autorise
le but premier c'est la livraison des
Services et malheureusement que ce soit
au niveau de la livraison des passeports
que ce soit au niveau de l'assurance
emploi monsieur Thibault encore à mon
bureau cette semaine on a des codes
assurance en poids qui traînent depuis
le mois de décembre de l'an dernier et
ça il faut que dans la négociation que
la prestation de service aux citoyens
soit au cœur de ce qui se discute à
table actuellement il y a pas que les
salaires il y a aussi les services aux
citoyens rapidement monsieur Bertin vous
l'avez dit tout à l'heure votre chef
votre chef a blâmer le gouvernement pour
l'ampleur qu'a pris la fonction publique
fédérale des dernières années est-ce
qu'un gouvernement conservateur
réduirait l'ampleur de la fonction
publique comme Monsieur Apple a fait à
l'époque quand il était au pouvoir en ce
moment monsieur
Thibault ce qu'on dit c'est que pour
tout nouveau programme on va devoir
trouver des économies équivalentes donc
on parle pas de baisser le nombre de
fonctionnaires on parle pas de couper
dans les services on dit que plutôt que
de faire comme le gouvernement de mettre
67 milliards de nouveaux programmes dans
le dernier budget on peut pas le faire
de manière continuelle sans arrêter il
faut trouver une manière de faire en
sorte que la fiscalité est juste pour
tous les Canadiens canadiens pour notre
génération mais pour toutes celles qui
vont suivre aussi très bien le Gardon
merci
Monsieur Thibault